see far as an organization that I  wouldn't have spent a decade with if I  didn't really believe that it was making  a huge difference it really is there to  try to improve humanity in the long run  I'm one of those people but we always  try to get as donors and participants  who just keep that he used the word  intellectually curious you know I'm just  really interested in all of these  various fields when I first came on the  board our main concern was just now on  earth is this organization go to  survived and have enough financing and  so on you can't do wonderful things with  a wonderful financing gradually more and  more people or governments and more  individuals have come to realize that  this is really doing a job and therefore  the support has increased so those kind  of changes have gradually evolved but it  takes somebody who is imaginative and it  was that sense of we can do this kind of  thing to make it happen